POLITICAL ANALYST NEW YORK TIMES
SENIOR POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT
TRUMP BIOGRAPHER MAGGIE HABERMAN
. UM FIRST OF ALL, MAGGIE, I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HEARD THE
RAMBLINGS SPEECH THE PRESIDENT
GAVE TONIGHT. WHAT DID YOU MAKE
OF THAT? WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS
ON THE DAY? THE DAY I ACTUALLY
THOUGHT WHEN, AS WELL AS IT
COULD HAVE GONE FOR TRUMP IN A
LOT OF WAYS, BECAUSE THIS IS AN
INDICTMENT THAT DID NOT HAVE AS
A BUNCH OF PEOPLE AND HIS TEAM
PUT IT TO ME A TON OF SURPRISES.
THEY FELT AS IF THEY WERE ABLE
TO DEAL WITH THIS WELL, AND THEN
HE GAVE A SPEECH WHERE HE DIDN'T
REALLY TALK ABOUT THAT
INDICTMENT VERY MUCH AT ALL. HE
DID DO EXACTLY WHAT HE WAS
WARNED AGAINST DOING BY THE
JUDGE, WHICH HAS TALKED ABOUT
THE PROSECUTOR AND HIS FAMILY
AND TALKED ABOUT THE JUDGE AND
HIS FAMILY, AND I DON'T KNOW HOW
THAT'S GOING TO GO OVER. IT HAS
A FEELING OF TRUMP IS ALMOST
DARING THE JUDGE TO ISSUE A GAG
ORDER, WHICH A LOT OF TRUMP
SUPPORTERS HAVE BEEN PREDICTING
DEFIANTLY WOULD HAPPEN. TRUMP AS
WE KNOW, PUSHES THE BOUNDS OF
CONDUCT OVER AND OVER AGAIN. I
EXPECT YOU WILL SEE THAT HERE.
BASICALLY HIS ARGUMENT IS WHAT
IT HAS BEEN, WHICH IS ANY
INVESTIGATION INTO ME IS UNJUST.
I WAS REALLY SURPRISED AT HOW
MUCH TIME HE SPENT TALKING ABOUT
THE MARA LAGO BOXES
INVESTIGATION, THE DOCUMENTS
CASE, WHICH WE KNOW HE HAS VERY
PREOCCUPIED WITH AND CONCERNED
ABOUT AND TALKS ABOUT A LOT. BUT
THAT WAS MUCH MORE TOP OF MIND
FOR HIM TONIGHT. CAITLIN WHAT
ARE YOU HEARING FROM YOUR
SOURCES? DOCUMENTS THING REALLY
STOOD OUT TO ME WHERE HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT ALSO SAYING THAT
PROSECUTORS OR INVESTIGATORS ARE
THREATENING PEOPLE WITH JAIL
TIME WHEN THEY'RE TRYING TO TALK
TO YOU. WE KNOW JACK SMITH, THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL HAS BEEN MOVING
VERY AGGRESSIVELY. VERY TIGHT
DEADLINES, NOT JUST FOR TRUMP
ATTORNEYS, BUT FOR WITNESSES
THAT THEY'VE BEEN SUBPOENAING.
WE CONFIRMED THE OTHER DAY THAT
THEY HAVE CAUGHT HIM MEMBERS OF
THE SECRET SERVICE TO COME IN
AND TESTIFY AS WELL. THEY'RE
BASICALLY ASKING ANYONE AND
EVERYONE HIS COMMENTS TONIGHT
SEEM TO INDICATE JUST SUCH A
HIGH LEVEL OF CONCERN WHEN IT
COMES TO THE DOCUMENTS
INVESTIGATION IN A REALLY
NOTABLE WAY. OBVIOUSLY, THE NEW
YORK CASES TOP OF MIND BECAUSE
THAT IS WHERE HE WAS TODAY. I
THINK HIS COMMENTS ABOUT THE
JUDGE WILL REALLY NOTABLE GIVEN
THAT WAS WHAT HIS LEGAL TEAM WAS
MOST WORRIED ABOUT GOING INTO
TODAY WAS WHAT HE WOULD SAY
ABOUT THAT. AND ABOUT ALVIN
BRAGG. BUT THE DOCUMENTS IN IT
REALLY STOOD OUT TO YOU HEARD
ANYTHING ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
BEHIND THE SCENES AT THE COURT
HOUSE. HOW IN THE COURTS
BUILDING WHAT THE PRESIDENT
THOUGHT ABOUT THE PROCESS OF
ACTUALLY BEING UNDER ARREST
DIDN'T ENJOY IT. ANDERSON WAS
GENERALLY HOW HAVE HAD A
DESCRIBED TO ME. I MEAN, HE
DIDN'T SPEAK TO CAMERAS, AND
CAITLIN KNOWS THAT SHE WAS THERE
, IN PART BECAUSE THE CAMERA HAD
BEEN PUSHED VERY FAR DOWN THE
HALL AND I THINK HE COULDN'T GET
CLOSE ENOUGH TO IT. BUT THAT WAS
SURPRISING THAT HE DIDN'T MAKE
AN ADDRESS AHEAD OF TIME OR
AFTER, BECAUSE WE HAVE BEEN
EXPECTING IT. HE WAS VERY ANGRY.
HE WAS NOT ENJOYING IT. THERE
WAS SOME LONGER PERIOD OF TIME
LEADING UP TO HIM GOING INTO THE
COURTROOM WHILE HE WAS BEING
PROCESSED, AND I STILL DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT ACCOUNTED. FOR
THAT DELAY, BUT SOMETHING DID
HAPPEN THERE. AND CAN I JUST SAY
ONE OTHER THING TODAY THAT ALSO
HAPPENED WAS THERE'S A INVITING
IN THE LEGAL TEAM OVER WHO IS
TAKING THE LEAD ON THE NEW YORK
CASE, AND YOU COULD SEE IT. THE
TRANSCRIPT WHERE THE PROSECUTORS
BROUGHT UP JOE TECH PENIS,
SAYING THAT HE MAY HAVE A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST WHEN IT
COMES TO STORY DANIELS, SAYING
THEY GOT A LETTER FROM HER
ATTORNEY YESTERDAY, IMPLYING
THAT HE DENIED IT. I SHOULD NOTE
TO THE JUDGE TODAY, IT WASN'T
EVEN A HEARING FOCUSED ON THAT
HE WENT OUT OF HIS WAY TO DENY
IT THAT COMES AFTER THEY BROUGHT
ON THAT NEW ATTORNEY THAT WAS
THERE TODAY, SO I DO THINK THERE
IS A LOT OF LEGAL ISSUE. ISSUES
AS WELL AS TO WHO IS ACTUALLY
DEFENDING TRUMP IN THE IN THE
LEAD POSITION ON THAT SITUATION
IN THE FORMER PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
FUNDRAISING ON THIS MAN. I'M NOT
SURE AT THIS POINT HOW MUCH THEY
HAVE RAISED. I'M NOT SURE HOW
MUCH MORE THEY RAISED TODAY.
THEY'RE NOW SELLING I GUESS T
SHIRTS WITH A FAKE MONK SHOT
THAT THEY HAVE DONE. HOW DO YOU
THINK? POLITICALLY THIS PLACE
FOR HIM IN THE COMING WEEKS AND
MONTHS. LISTEN, THIS WASN'T A
GOOD DAY FOR DONALD TRUMP,
MASTER OF, YOU KNOW, TAKING
LEMONS AND MAKING LEMONADE. HE
LIKES THE THEATRICS. HE LIKES TO
KIND OF BUILD UP THE BRANDING
AROUND THIS WE HAD HEARD, YOU
KNOW, THERE WERE NEGOTIATIONS OF
DOING SOMETHING EVEN MORE
POTENTIALLY SCALED BACK THEN
WHAT WE SAW TODAY HE WANTED THE
MUG SHOT. HE WANTED THAT IMAGERY
OF THE DEFIANT LEADER, YOU KNOW,
TAKING ON THE ESTABLISHMENT, AND
IT'S WORKING. THAT'S THE PROBLEM
IS WE LIKE WE'RE SEEING IT. ALL
THE POLLS ARE SHOWING HE IS
LEADING THE FACT THAT THE OTHER
REPUBLICANS IN THE FIELD ARE
COMING OUT AND DEFENDING HIM. IT
IS HARD, YOU KNOW, AT THIS
JUNCTURE IN A PRIMARY SEASON IF
PEOPLE ARE NOT WILLING TO
CHALLENGE FOR EXAMPLE, THIS
INDICTMENT OR ANY OF THE OTHER
INVESTIGATIONS INTO HIM WHAT
LANE IS THERE TO RUN AGAINST HIM
IN BECAUSE THIS IS NOT GOING
WHERE HE'S NOT A SUBSTANTIVE
PERSON? WE'RE NOW YOU KNOW,
SEVEN YEARS INTO THIS ENDEAVOR.
THIS ISN'T SOMETHING WHERE
PEOPLE VOTE FOR HIM PURELY ON
POLICY. IT'S THE CHARACTERS THAT
THE ASTERISK THEATRICS THAT
FOLLOW HIM. HE IS. HE'S TAKING
UP ALL THE OXYGEN IN THE ROOM,
AND I THINK HE'S MAKING THE MOST
OF IT ALSO MAKES IT IMPOSSIBLE
FOR OTHER REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES
TO TALK ABOUT ACTUAL ISSUES.
HE'S NOT LOOKING TO TALK ABOUT
ISSUES, NOT AND I MEAN LOOK,
LOOK AT THE ARC OF THE DAY HE
STARTS OFF AS A SMALL GUY IN A
SMALL CARAVAN, YOU KNOW, WITH A
SMALL ENTOURAGE GOING INTO A BIG
BUILDING AND YOU CAN SEE ON HIS
FACE. THAT IT'S YOU KNOW, HE'S
GONE FROM REALITY TV TO REALITY
THAT THIS IS REAL. THIS IS NOT
JUDGE JUDY. THIS IS A REAL
SITUATION AND HE LOOKS SHAKEN
UP. HE LOOKS ASHEN. BUT THEN HE
GETS TO GET AND
GO TO HIS BIG RESORT AND HAVE A
BIG EVENT AND THERE'S SOMETHING
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING TO ME,
THAT'S VERY DISTURBING. THAT
HE'S KIND OF SLIPPED THE NOOSE
EVEN TODAY, AND IT'S SOMEHOW
HAVING THE CONVERSATION. HE
WANTS TO HAVE A BALANCE NOT TO
WANT TO TALK ABOUT. HE'S NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE COUNTRY, NOT
EVEN TALKING ABOUT THE CASE.
HE'S JUST, YOU KNOW, PULLING
PEOPLE DOWN TO HIS OWN MIRROR
WORLD AND I'M AFRAID IT'S GOING
TO BE WORKING. I THINK IT'S UP
TO REPUBLICANS TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO GET US OUT OF THIS SITUATION
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT GOOD. THEY
DON'T KNOW HOW REPUBLICANS KNEW
HOW TO DO THAT. I THINK THAT WE
WOULD HAVE SEEN IT A LONG TIME
AGO. AND I DO THINK THAT THAT IS
A POINT THAT YOU'RE MAKING. AND
AS A POINT OF THIS IS MAKING,
YOU KNOW, WE HEAR A LOT FROM
PEOPLE AROUND RHONDA SANTOS, FOR
INSTANCE, THAT HE'S NOT CHANGING
HOW HE'S BEHAVING BASED ON
DONALD TRUMP. HE'S GOING TO RUN
HIS GAME. DONALD TRUMP IS DOING
WHAT HE'S DOING, AND THAT'S FINE
EXCEPT THAT DONALD TRUMP WAS
CARRIED LIVE ON FOX NEWS
TONIGHT. THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN
THAT OFTEN ANYMORE. AND THAT
TELLS YOU A LOT ABOUT HOW THE
OXYGEN IS GETTING SUCKED, AND I
DON'T THINK REPUBLICANS NO HOW
TO GO WITH DONALD TRUMP. I DON'T
THINK THEY HAVE EVER KNOWN HOW
TO GO AT DONALD TRUMP. I DON'T
THINK THAT'S CHANGED. I DO THINK
HE HAS, IN SOME WAYS TIGHTENED
HIS HOLD ON THE PARTY, EVEN AS
HIS SUPPORT HAS SLIPPED. I'LL
JUST SAY THAT ALVIN BRAGG MADE
IT MUCH MORE DIFFICULT TODAY TO
GO AT DONALD TRUMP. ALVIN BRAGG
PROVIDED FODDER FOR REPUBLICANS
TO SAY, LOOK, THIS IS WHAT'S
GOING ON. THIS IS WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO DONALD TRUMP CAN
POINT TO ALVIN BRAGG AND SAY.
I'M BEING ATTACKED, AND IT'S
HARD FOR REPUBLICANS TO SAY,
WELL, NO, HE'S REALLY NOT WHEN,
IN FACT WHEN MITT ROMNEY COMES
OUT AND DEFENDS DONALD TRUMP,
YOU KNOW THERE'S A PROBLEM.
THERE'S NO SPACE FOR, UH, MIKE
PENCE OR A CHRISTIAN, YOU KNOW,
OR SOMEONE ELSE WHO'S GETTING IN
THE RACE TO SAY, LET ME PUT SOME
DAYLIGHT HERE. LET ME TRY TO
LIKE SEPARATE MYSELF. HOW CAN
YOU DO THAT IN THIS IN THIS
INSTANCE WHEN WE HAVE THIS CASE
RIGHT HERE, THIS INDICTMENT,
WHICH IS LARGELY IS, THE POLL
SAID. BASED ON POLITICS AND KEEP
IN MIND TODAY, NIKKI HALEY WAS
AT THE BORDER. I BELIEVE MIKE
POMPEO TRAVELED TO UKRAINE AND
THOSE THINGS ARE NOT BREAKING
THROUGH. WHAT'S BREAKING THROUGH
IS THE IS THE MESSAGE IS, YOU
KNOW, LAW ENFORCEMENT IS BEING
WEAPONIZED AGAINST US. THE
SYSTEM IS BEING WEAPONIZED